okay hello everyone welcome to another
episode of science and technology q a
for kids and others and i see there are
a bunch of questions saved up here but
i'm happy to see
new ones come in
so there was a question here
about artificial general intelligence
should an international agreement be
created so that artificial general
intelligence has rights before agis
exists so they feel their rights are
respected so let's let's um
uh talk a little bit about where that
all comes from
so first question is
what what is artificial general
intelligence does it even mean anything
what kind of a thing might that mean
you know
long time ago when computers were first
being developed in 1940s 1950s and so on
people often referred to them by terms
like giant electronic brains and kind of
the general assumption and belief was
that just as people had managed to make
you know machinery that would uh you
know pick up heavier loads than humans
could and things like that that it
wouldn't be long before
one would be able to make things that
were sort of better stronger brainier
than human brains that in a sense just
like you know the bulldozer or something
had cracked the code of how you how you
move objects around that uh that are
heavier than humans can move so
similarly that these sort of electronic
brains
that were what people call computers um
would be able to do the kinds of sort of
thinking tasks better than humans
well it didn't work out that way
and
it was
it was interesting that it didn't work
out that way i think
that there were a series of tasks where
people said i wonder if computers are
going to be able to do this
examples playing chess
being able to translate from one
language to another
being able to recognize an image in a
picture
being able to
uh drive a car on a street autonomously
these kinds of things being able to do
mathematical calculations
so
people said you know
at the beginning in the 1950s early
1960s people said you know when when
artificial intelligence ai was first
being talked about people said look the
test is will computers be able to do you
know college level math will computers
be able to translate from one language
to another
and each there was a series of these
tests and i mentioned most of the main
ones i think right right there
um and people said well when computers
can do this and this and this then we'll
know computers are um you know are smart
like people well what people assumed was
that in order to solve those problems
you would have to make a brain like
thing but a better than a brain brain
like thing to do them but that isn't how
it actually worked out
i mean for example the majority of like
math that gets done by computers is done
by mathematica and our software systems
and so on
and the way that that we do calculus for
example by computer is not kind of an
extension of the way that humans do
calculus it is using completely
different methodology that is really
good for a machine
and quite inappropriate for humans it
involves kind of very systematic but
very many operations required kinds of
things to be done
so
uh
as opposed to where the human where it's
like well i kind of remember it looks
more or less like this let me try that
etc etc etc now each one of these tasks
has gotten done in different ways like
for example
um
and
there are so things like mathematics
there are these kind of algorithms these
methods that let you do it using uh
techniques that are very non-human
one of the things that was a long
holdout was things like image
recognition you know is this picture a
picture of a cat or a dog
things like that
that was something which was very hard
for computers to do people hadn't
figured out how to make that work
and there was kind of an annual
competition of people with with lots of
different images of you know how what's
the fraction of the time you can get it
right whether it's a cat or a dog those
kinds of things and finally around 2012
uh sort of a surprise happened that that
some techniques that were originally
invented in the 1940s and that were kind
of modeled on the ways that brains work
neural network techniques
actually started working and started
being able to for example do those kinds
of uh distinguish a cat from a dog
picture
and in a sense the way those things work
is a little bit like the way the the
some parts of our brains work maybe
let's not talk about this in great
detail here but but essentially what
what's happening is one is saying here's
a lot of examples of pictures of cats
there's a lot of examples of pictures of
dogs we will uh set up our sort of
uh essential essentially mathematical
system to be able to recognize when the
thing that you're now being shown is
close to an example of a cat versus as
close to an example of a dog and that
sort of machine learning training idea
is an idea that worked for that
particular case
uh
different the the i think so they're
these different examples of of things
where people
uh for the for the case of things like
object recognition image uh visual
object recognition neural nets work well
for
things there are plenty of things where
for mathematics they do not work well um
they might work well for making some
sort of judgment calls about should i
try using this method or that method for
the mathematics but once you're using
the method the method is not very much
uh sort of a a neural net let me roughly
follow an example kind of thing it's
more like a definite method a different
algorithm like you know adding numbers
or something would be a definite
algorithm rather than let me do it by by
example so to speak
so
any case these these specific things
that people sort of said are we going to
be able to do these with machines a lot
of them got done
uh one of the ones that was a long
holdout was uh general question
answering so like questions about the
world like uh you know which is closer
you know mars or the sun
or um
what uh
uh you know do
um do elephants eat
uh potatoes or something uh you know
these kinds of um that
the the uh um you know these these types
of sort of general knowledge about the
world types of questions that have been
a long holdout and and i've been
interested in that question actually
well kind of since i was a kid you know
could we encode information in such a
way that one could automatically answer
questions if those questions were
answerable with kind of the uh the
knowledge that our civilization has and
i i long thought that to be able to
answer questions like those you really
would have to have kind of a a
brain-like
general intelligence kind of thing
and then as a result of a bunch of
science that i did in the in the 1990s
and and uh
and so on i kind of came to the
conclusion that that couldn't be the
case that there wasn't something that
you could distinguish in terms of the
intelligent from the merely
computational so that got me started
building our wolfram alpha system which
came out in 2009 which is a question
answering system and in which
a lot of kind of the knowledge of the
world is built in
and we also sort of solved the problem
of being able to understand natural
language questions about things about
the world and i think people who'd
worked on artificial intelligence for a
long time were very surprised to see
wolfman alpha because they kind of
assumed like i did had done that to make
a system like that that does kind of
general question answering you'd have to
build a kind of a general intelligence
but you don't
instead it's something where what's
happening is we're taking the natural
language question
i don't know you know how many people
live in paris
and we're turning that into our
computational language uh you know
entity paris france you know property
population compute you know etc
um
and and then generating the answer on
the basis of data that we have curated
um or for example in the case of you
know which is fosa mars or the sun um
there you might actually have to compute
something about the uh you know if mars
on the opposite side of the sun right
now then it's further away than the sun
so you actually have to do a computation
you have to figure out distances and and
so on and you're using essentially
physics
and some mathematics to be able to to do
that
and the whole point of wolfman alpha is
to sort of collect all of the known
algorithms and methods and and so on for
doing those kinds of things so that you
can ask that question just a natural
language it'll be converted into this uh
symbolic computational language then
compute the answer so then say the
result back
but
again
the
you know you might have thought that oh
it should be done kind of like a human
does it but it isn't it's done
in ways that are uh you know it's
converting to this computational
language that's different from what
humans intrinsically deal with and then
it's doing computations in a way that's
different from the way humans do it
so this
idea that there should be sort of a a
general
um
you know what's this notion of a general
intelligence okay so a couple of things
to say about that
one is
one of the early ideas along these lines
came from alan turing who was kind of
invented turing machines was a pioneer
in the whole notion of computation back
in the 1930s and in 1950 he kind of
wrote this um article about sort of what
could computers be like in the end and
he invented this test so-called turing
test where you imagine that you have
uh a thing in another room and you're
talking to it you don't know if it's a
computer or a person you get to ask it a
bunch of questions and the issue is the
touring test is can you tell is the
thing in the other room a computer or is
it a person
and that's kind of been one of the kind
of uh sort of criteria for general
intelligence is can you pass the turing
test can you have a thing which you
could talk to
and it will kind of uh
have a discussion like you might have a
discussion with a person
now people built back in the 1960s there
was a thing called the liza that was
built which was a very simple kind of
chatbot thing where you talk to it and
it was kind of imitating a psychiatrist
and and it was going to um kind of you
know you'd say um something and it would
say how do you feel about that or you'd
say something else it would it would
make some response
um
it i have to say one of the things
that's been a surprise is that chatbot
technology has not advanced that much at
least in terms of the general have a
have a general
small talk conversation with your with
your computer the thing that's advanced
dramatically is being able to have a
content full discussion with your
computer i mean for example people have
used wolf and alpha and put it into chat
bots to who are trying to win the
touring uh you know win this touring
test uh competition
um and
you know having wolf and alpha in there
is actually kind of a downer because if
you want to know is this in fact a chat
bot a computer uh connected to wolf
malfur all you have to do is ask a bunch
of really weird general knowledge
questions no human will be able to
answer all of those but wolfman alpha
can certainly answer them and then it
kind of reveals that the chatbot has a
computer behind it you know is a
computer so to speak it has wolfen alpha
behind it
so it's a little odd but the fact is
that you know having a kind of small
talk discussion with your ai
is something that hasn't really been
convincingly achieved there are plenty
of of chat bots where people can have
kind of fun amusing conversations but
you kind of know it's a computer back
there or you should
and i think you know part of the issue
is well you know if you look at what do
people talk about when they're just
having small talk type discussions i
have to admit that i personally am never
very good at those things i'm i'm uh
i have a terrible habit of always
wanting to talk to people about
something that is sort of real content
factual type stuff so i i think i might
fail the turing test just as a human so
to speak um but uh
um i think that the um uh this this
notion of of what do you talk about well
often when humans sort of have small
talk discussions with each other they're
talking about very human kinds of things
and they're not issues that the computer
is uh the you know they're not part of
its everyday experience if you are this
ai that's sitting in a box on somebody
on a desk somewhere you don't really
have you know oh
you know it's nice weather today
you know it was pleasant walking outside
type thing you know it's a very weird
thing for the box on the desk to be
talking about and it isn't sort of its
context in the world is different from
human context in the world
now another thing
that
is
sort of makes people think about
artificial votes general intelligence
is this idea that that there is a notion
of general intelligence for humans
which is something that comes out i
guess from the 1930s
um there was kind of a uh i think
originally it was for
for testing for things like the army and
so on it's like okay
is this
a person who is good for this kind of
role or is this a person who's good for
that kind of role
and sort of there are people who are
better at some things better at other
things somebody who's stronger runs
faster somebody who can sort of figure
out some code faster than somebody else
these are different kinds of skills and
there was sort of a desire to to you
know put people to do the skills that
they should be doing and one of the
things that then arose was this idea of
oh there's this notion of general
intelligence
which would be a a segmenter of what
people can do and so that led to this
idea it was usually called g the general
intelligence quotient which led to the
whole iq intelligence quotient type type
idea it's a very weird notion it's this
notion of well you know there are things
people have to do in the world
and it's like is there a notion of
general intelligence that lets you do
things better well it kind of depends
what those things are because there are
things like well can you sort of tell
what another person is thinking can you
solve a kind of a sort of math puzzle
problem can you creatively uh work out
some engineering solution can you do
this can you do that these are all
different kinds of things and they it is
hard to
believe that there is a kind of a common
theme to to being able to do all of
those better um and
you know it could be that you know
we have lots of
if you look at any particular attribute
i mean there are you know people can run
faster people can
sort of you know
um
uh you know be more precise in making
some in drawing some picture they you
know all sorts of different attributes
but the notion that sort of everything
that could be done is bundled together
and you can say this person is better
than that person and everything is i
think a rather unconvincing one is a
friend of mine named howard gardner
who's a psychologist who's who's um
pushed quite a lot this multiple
intelligences idea where he kind of
distinguishes a fixed set of i don't
know how many it is i think it increases
over time but you know of a dozen or so
different kind of dimensions of
intelligence i think even that's
probably uh sort of more simplistic
although it's perhaps more useful than
having a single notion of general
intelligence so to speak but what
happened back in the 1930s it sort of uh
you know
crawled towards modern times
is that people say well let's make a
test for you know general intelligence
and that led to sort of these iq test
type things and there were oh i don't
know you know whatever what are they
called ravens progressive matrices or
something where it's like here are these
shapes and which shape fits into that
shape and which is out of place and this
and what comes next in this sequence and
so on and so on and so on
um well that tests something whether it
tests things you need to be able to sort
of creatively solve problems or to be
able to do this or that uh probably not
um it is
you know in some sense intelligence
tests like that test how good you are at
doing intelligence tests like that
um which uh uh but in any case that that
kind of idea that there is a notion of a
sort of a general intelligence test i
think led to some of this kind of in
some ways rather uh
rather overly simplistic thinking about
oh well let's just make our computers
you know maybe today our computers will
behave as if they have an iq of 50 and
maybe later they'll behave as if they
have an iq of 300. you know i'm not even
sure what that would mean
um and uh the um
the thing that um uh but that's kind of
been a kind of a notion that people have
sometimes had that that we're on this
kind of progression that computers will
get quote smarter and smarter whatever
that means
um i think that a lot of the um so so i
think this notion
that um now now when having said that
that's sort of the question of well what
do you have be done with a computer
versus what do you have be done by
person
and that's a moving target i mean the
the uh uh but sometimes what happens is
the way things get done by computer is
very different from the way you kind of
expected them to be get
done by computer in the days of when
alan turing was writing his turing test
thing there was this notion of well we
would fundamentally communicate with our
computers by typing messages to them and
they would be typing back you know you
say what's the answer to this and then
you would get back a textual answer to
that question type thing now one thing
that that just didn't think of was
visual display of information so for
example i remember oh it must have been
20 years ago now 15 years ago whatever i
remember i noticed you go to a movie
theater
and there were sort of two options for
how to get a ticket one is you walk up
to a kiosk and you ask a person the
other is you use a machine which you
know where you press a touch screen and
it's giving a visual display of what the
possibilities are and so on so there was
a period of time when when you know the
line for the but asking the person was a
long line and there was nobody ever uh
you know nobody except kind of people
like me ever went to the machine and
sort of talked to the machine so to
speak
but and then then that kind of
dramatically over a period about a year
or so switched over and and it's you
know to the point where it's like only a
few people go talk to the person most of
them are lined up waiting to talk to the
machine so to speak but one of the
points there was that the way in which
one interacted with the machine
where you might have said oh you need to
solve the problem of having a whole
transaction of discussion about movie
tickets and so on well no actually
because the machine can present this
information in the user interface in a
way that a human can easily pick off
press this button to press this button
and so on and you kind of don't have to
solve the problem of having that
elaborate discussion which might say oh
is there a seven o'clock showing of that
movie et cetera et cetera et cetera so
it kind of got solved in a different way
and i think that that is the case with a
lot of these things where people say
let's make human-like intelligence
artificial intelligence it's like well
actually the solution to that problem is
better done the technology allows one to
solve that problem in a way that's
different from the way that one would do
it if one had humans solving that
problem i mean it's kind of like the
issue if you're trying to fly you can do
it like a bird and flap your wings and
so on and when people first started
thinking about making airplanes they
assumed that airplanes would have to
have flapping wings turns out that the
flapping part just isn't that important
to flying and there's different ways to
solve the problem particularly if you're
making the thing out of rigid metal you
know things rather than out of bones and
muscles and feathers and so on there are
different ways to solve that problem and
so it has been with a lot of these
things which are kind of in the
artificial intelligence type direction
and i think then the the the question of
when do we put different kinds of things
under the control of of computers rather
than humans interesting question there
are a series of things where that's
happening from um you know autopilots
for planes which are quite old to
self-driving cars
to
controlling
um
all sorts of i don't know medical
devices to
having uh you know to deciding oh we
should have
this or that financial system controlled
by an ai rather than by people these
kinds of things and one of the things
that starts to happen is
then you have to ask the question okay
you're going to generally you're going
to say okay ai is in control of setting
up this i don't know this bank interest
rate or some such other thing but they
have to tell it so what do you roughly
want the ai to do because one feature of
the ai is it does not have an intrinsic
notion of kind of what its goal is
you know it's it's just some computer
sitting there it's doing something but
it's whereas we humans have whatever
reason all sorts of built-in goals you
know we really want to achieve this or
that we really want to we
we feel like we have some sort of
purpose in life to do something um
that's it's very different for for an ai
it just is doing what it's doing and
there's no notion of a kind of a
built-in purpose
unless we sort of put it there and then
we kind of have to define what is it
that we want the ai to do and so that
gets us kind of into this notion of kind
of computational language and this
notion of so how do you specify what you
want the ai to do it's kind of like if
you imagine
um it's like a contract with the ai that
says um
uh what
um you know like you might have a legal
contract with a person or a company um
and which defines what should happen and
what you want to have happen so
similarly you need such a sort of
contract with your ai about what you
want it to do but you need that contract
in a computational language that both
you understand and the ai understands
and needless to say that our whole world
from language technology stack seems
extremely relevant to to to writing such
kinds of computational contracts that
refer to things in the real world but
allow you to kind of define sort of
procedures for what should happen with
things
um i think
so
that's uh and by the way when it comes
to sort of so what do we want the ais to
do that leads on to some very
interesting questions i mean if we you
know if we allow ais to control more of
the world we allow ais i don't know we
you know we we start having military ais
that are like controlling you know
autonomous tanks or drones or whatever
else and then we say well what do we
want those ais what what rules do we
want those ais to follow
and uh you know they could potentially
be doing very powerful things what do we
want them to do
and uh and what uh you know what
ultimate basis do we want some ethics
for the ais what do we want to put into
the sort of base base ethics of the ais
and so that leads on to kind of this
question of sort of you know imagine you
were making a sort of constitution for
the ais what should it look like i was
just thinking about this actually
recently and it's quite an interesting
question to me you know imagine that the
us constitution was being written not
240 years ago whatever it is but instead
today with all the technological issues
we have today
and and ais what would it say
and you know what would it say about uh
what uh you know what was possible on on
the sort of shared resource of the
internet what would it say about sort of
privacy what would it say about sort of
neural connections to brains what would
it say about all kinds of medical
possibilities what would it say about
all sorts of things um and it's sort of
an interesting question and and the
original you know when the us
constitution was written there were a
bunch of kind of philosophical
influences
that um
were quite new at the time actually um
that were somewhere not so new some came
from ancient greek times and so on but
but someone knew at the time and they
were um and you know when
if you read the these these kinds of
things the
you know some of the phraseologies kind
of gives away you know even statements
like we hold these truths to be
self-evident which is kind of a a an
almost philosophical statement it's not
what does what is a self-evident truth
that's not that's a concept that's a
philosophical concept which is some uh
so it's sort of interesting to ask the
question particularly with what we know
now
in uh in sort of the science and the
sort of philosophical consequences of
science
how would that affect what is the modern
analog of these kinds of things and how
would that allow one to construct sort
of the modern computational constitution
so to speak which by the way might be
something relevant not only for the
operation of the human world but also
for the operation of the ai ai world so
to speak and that's sort of a place
where this interaction between sort of
the the the ais and uh and humans is
important i mean for example right now
you know ai's have a big effect on our
world i mean one obvious place says if
you go search for something on the web
or you have a a news feed and social
media
the ordering of things that come out
there that's all determined by an ai
in the end the ai has been told what is
your objective or the objective is you
know maximize the ad revenue for the
company that's that's putting the thing
up there or some such other thing but
the the details of how that works
is all done by ai so to speak and that's
the thing where we are directly kind of
the you know under the we are the
subjects of the ai it's like the ai is
kind of operating like a rule of law of
the government or something and we are
we're subject to that as as we uh you
know experience these things that ais
produce and insofar as people don't like
everything that's produced there that's
kind of the first kind of uh uh you know
friction with with kind of ai types of
things and maybe ultimately a friction
of with the owners of the ais but uh uh
more immediately a friction with the ais
themselves
so
in any case i think this question of of
uh sort of okay so that that one one
starts thinking about computational
constitutions
um that brings up questions about should
ais have rights
and under what circumstances
is it sort of a shocking thing to to
switch off your ai you know under what
circumstances do you feel like uh you
know the memory of the ai
is something that uh uh is is is wrong
ethically or something else to just
switch off in a race
and when you say it's just an ai
you know it's not um uh you know it's a
different thing from a human humans are
different
uh humans are different you know certain
kinds of animals might be different but
others are not you know we don't worry
about making the virus extinct i don't
think um we kind of think that's a good
thing um we uh uh it's some uh you know
it's a the question is under what
circumstances for example an ai that has
had all these experiences and has you
know uh and has this sort of rich
uh
rich interaction so here's an example
actually just occurs to me
let's say that the ai
is
an important friend or supporter
of assistant two or something a bunch of
humans
okay then the question is does that
affect does the entanglement of the ai
with the human world affect one's
feeling about the rights or the ethics
of switching off the ai or does one only
say that the ai's only reason to not be
switched off is the the harm that it
would cause to the humans who are
friends of the ai so to speak or at what
point does the ai itself intrinsically
raise to the level rise to the level
where you could say it should be have
the right to stay
you know the right to um you know life
liberty and the pursuit of happiness so
to speak um and uh you know in in um
when the when the ai you know when does
it have its own intrinsic right to stay
switched on so to speak and does that
does it get that right by virtue of uh
kind of its entanglement with the human
world or does it get it for some more
intrinsic reason i mean in the past
there have often been kind of uh sort of
theological or religious
kinds of uh concepts for sort of how
certain rights are intrinsic um if one
if one sort of uh if one takes that out
of the picture and doesn't try to apply
that to ai's because that gets really
weird um the uh i mean that's an
interesting question
is kind of the um
uh well in any case but but um um
i think the uh you know that then the
question is sort of where might the
rights of the ais sort of intrinsically
flow from and is it is it a consequence
of their entanglement with the human
world and so on
now i have to say
i sort of for fun and uh
i suppose
to amuse my children although they're
now mostly grown up and no longer
as amused by such things but i have to
say that i for a long time would take
the point of view that you could always
you know when you were dealing with some
machine that was doing something you
should always sort of say thank you to
the machine
um and uh you know i sort of would would
make comments like you know you never
know what's being you know what the
machine is recorded and uh you know in
the future the machine will appreciate
the fact that you always appreciated the
machine that's kind of just for fun but
but there's this sort of question of of
does it become
and that's again a complicated issue
because it's like
uh you know do you thank the machine
because you are doing something for the
machine or do you thank the machine
because that does something for you
um and anyway it gets complicated but i
think that this um this question of of
what
might
cause ais
to
us to feel that ais should have or have
to have rights i mean there's sort of a
question of as we build up our kind of
system of computational constitution and
so on does it become the case that the
thing falls apart unless
ai's have rights in certain cases i
don't know
i remember there was a company that i
was a little bit involved with which
unfortunately didn't make it that had
this idea of having autonomous bots
that would exist in social media
platforms and things like that
which would be kind of which would exist
for themselves so for example a bot
would be kind of a
a an account that was controlled by an
ai
and that account it would learn some
jokes and it would start sending out it
would start you know sending messages
with those jokes to people it would
notice which people found the jokes more
amusing would have some whole you know
learning machine learning kind of thing
which would decide whether whether to
send you know this person those jokes or
that person those jokes it would kind of
develop from there and the concept was
that eventually because of the way a lot
of these platforms work maybe the thing
would start making videos or podcasts or
something like that and it would it
would start getting you know monetizing
those things and pretty soon
the ai the completely autonomous ai that
had been launched by a human
but was then autonomously operating in
social media would then make a living
for itself and it would maybe it would
become a you know for all one knows it
would become you know an influencer and
uh be uh you know it would get um
endorsement deals and who knows what and
it would um it would gradually make a
living for itself
and that's some that's a that was sort
of an interesting concept i i thought it
would really interesting to see what
would happen with that and would you get
a situation in which you had these
things that really were no longer human
connected that were just making a living
for themselves so to speak and they were
they were kind of paying for their own
you know computer electricity or
something or paying for their own
uh you know licensing of content or
whatever else
um but it didn't it didn't it didn't
work out i think partly because some of
the social media companies were like you
can't put a bot on our thing it has to
be tied to a human i i'm not sure that
that's always a challenging thing
of uh kind of you know is there a human
at the end of the chain so to speak and
and what is that human like and is it
the human you thought it was and and
there are more and more elaborate
schemes to try and figure out you know
are you a human are you alive are you
you know there's this liveness testing
is a common kind of concept of you know
you'll get on some some website and it
will say you know it'll look at you with
it with your computer's camera it'll say
you know turn your head to the right
turn your head to the left and so on and
it has some way of knowing you know is
that really what you're doing is that is
that um and can you respond to
in that way and so on and this question
of you know is it an actual human at the
end of the chain so to speak
well anyway long long question there
long answer to a question about about
ais
um
the uh
aaron is asking how could one perform a
turing test for this live stream
that's a good question you know i am i
am hoping to have a bot of myself one
day uh you know anybody who i've spent
well the majority of my life actually uh
the ceo of a company and in a sense
that's like
um
you're you know you're delegating a lot
of things you might do yourself but but
you have talented people who can do them
as well as you could do them and maybe
better and
so you know the ultimate delegation is
to delegate some part of your life to a
pure bot that is um that is doing the
things that you would otherwise do and
it's like i get all sorts of email about
all sorts of things and it's uh
it's terribly complicated to respond to
it and i i've just i i wish there were a
bot
but then you know it's kind of a weird
thing because because some of that email
sort of the very point of it is
connection between people and then if
there's a bot that's doing it what does
that mean and and then do people get
connected to the bot rather than to the
person and it all gets very complicated
and it's all kind of
a complicated thing to think about for
the future um but uh
um
yeah you know i i think we're still some
distance away from being able to do this
live stream uh purely with a bot of me
um but uh it will be interesting when
that becomes possible
um
let's see
uh
rather technical questions here well
um
let's talk about one here
um
[Music]
talk about one from harry
about uh brain computer interfaces
so
normally our brains get input
in specific ways they get input from our
eyes you know light falls on our retina
that produces an electrical signal which
goes through our optic nerve and in a
rather a piece of apparently rather bad
design for our brains the eyes are at
the front of our head and the first
level of visual processing is right at
the back of our heads and so the optic
nerve has to go all the way through the
center of our brain to get to the back
of the back of the brain for to get
processed
um and and even more bizarrely there's a
crossover from between our two eyes it
crosses over in a in the middle of our
brains um to to get to so the the left
visual cortex is dealing with the right
eye primarily although they are somewhat
inter-interwoven um
and but in any case the you know in a
first approximation the way our brain
gets gets things into it is from our
eyes there are about 10 million fibers
in the optic nerve that deliver uh you
know
roughly well i don't know
10-ish times some number of tens of
times per second they basically deliver
the current state of our visual uh of
the visual field then we have our
auditory nerve from our ears there are
about 50 000 nerve fibers i think in the
auditory nerve which are delivering
sound signals uh from our ears then
there are lots of touch sensors that we
have on the on the on the surface of our
skin and so on and there are some number
of uh of sensors that tell you kind of
the your muscle uh the positions of
things and the uh and elongation of
muscles and things like that um and uh
and let's see what else is that that's
about it that's that's where we get
information so we have a certain flow of
information into our brains in terms of
getting out of our brains we are
primarily the primary way that we that
things come out of our brains is through
actuating our muscles whether those are
muscles for moving around or whether
those are muscles for talking that's the
primary stuff that comes out of our
brain
so the question is can we have a more
and so like for example if we want to
interact with the computer we can see
what is on its screen you know the the
the information from the computer gets
into our eyes goes to our visual cortex
goes into our brain
and we can communicate with the computer
by like typing with our fingers and
moving our muscles and so on but the
question is is there a more direct way
that we could be kind of plugged into
our computer could we
uh could we kind of
have
for example could we have our computer
um more directly sense things from our
brains without it having without us
having to move our muscles and and type
with our fingers and so on
and people have been trying to do
experiments on that forever and ever and
i have to say back by i think of the
1950s there were experiments done on
this the thing is that our brain you can
pick up electrical activity from our
brain the eeg
electroencephalography um and uh the um
there's a signal because our because our
neuro the neurons in our brains
are electrical devices the way that they
uh that there are you know
roughly um
uh
100 billion neurons in our brains
um
and
those each of those neurons maybe a
thousand times a second
is well not each one but but
maybe any given neuron every maybe every
second or something i don't know um is
producing a little electrical signal
which is then being communicated to
other neurons and that's kind of how the
fundamental operation of the brain works
is this whole network of connections
between neurons some neurons might be
connected to 10 000 other neurons it's a
very well connected kind of setup
but in any case each one of those uh
electrical signals
electrical the the there's a sort of a
spike of electrical activity from a
neuron that transmits to another neuron
and you can in principle detect that you
can detect that electrical spike
now in some organisms um
famously the the squid has a giant axon
an extremely big single nerve fiber
where it's really easy to pick up the
the electrical signals of the giant axon
of the squid
um but uh with with us humans every
single neuron in our brains just like
every single
uh nerve in that that runs through the
rest of our body there are electrical
signals associated with the activity of
those nerves and you can pick that up by
something that detects electrical
activity you can pick it up by its
electrical effect you can pick it up by
its magnetic effect and so on
but in fact with our brains
with our 100 billion neurons there are
some collective effects so if you just
put electrodes on your on your head and
you say what do you pick up well what
you mostly pick up is a is a great big
rhythm of about um
maybe nine cycles per second or
something um of uh at least when you're
awake um a big sort of overall rhythm of
your brain
and there are lots of sub rhythms and
when you go to sleep there's different
rhythms that develop and so on but these
are big collective effects they're big
effects that
uh
sort of affect your whole brain
and um those are pretty easy to pick up
in in various situations whether it's in
epilepsy or maybe in migraines there are
different sort of overall patterns of
electrical activity in the brain um that
can have effects but for
you know one's brain in sort of its
normal operating conditions
there's this rhythm of this this um uh a
particular brainwave rhythm
that exists and there are as i say lots
of sub rhythms it's a very complicated
thing to interpret and you know you
close your eyes you'll get a different
rhythm and this happens and that happens
but these are large-scale collective
effects in the brain not things that are
at the level of individual neurons and
when we imagine how sort of thinking
works in the brain it's very much at the
level of complicated patterns of
individual neurons like we know in the
visual cortex in the in the um
that deals with sight that every cell on
our retina it's like every pixel on our
camera um is sort of feeding particular
cells particular neurons in our visual
cortex which are connected to other
neurons and they do various kinds of
analysis and they recognize object
boundaries of objects and then they go
to higher level things and that's it's
kind of a whole elaborate thing but but
basically the sort of the stuff that's
relevant to kind of the processing and
information in the brain is happening
very much at the individual neuron level
so
the the knowing these brain waves
doesn't really give you a lot of
information about the sort of individual
level activity in the brain
now it is the case that for example if
you're going to move your finger
there is uh sort of you generate a whole
bunch of electrical activity in a
particular region of your brain on the
motor strip i think it's around around
there um the um uh and um uh maybe you
could pick up
the electrical activity associated with
that it's difficult to do that
through
a skull
because the electrical signal is kind of
fuzzed out by by all the stuff of you
know the convenient thing of the skull
so to speak between the brain which has
all these neurons with electrical
activity and the the the scalp where you
actually put the electrode i always used
to think that um you know one of the
advantages of what if all my hair fell
out would be easy to to sort of uh you
know wear those electrodes that would
let me type faster i'm afraid that
didn't come to pass doesn't really make
much difference actually um you can
stick the electrodes on anyway and we
don't have good ways to let you type by
thought um but it is the case that if
you if you try and see those electrical
activities in the brain uh you know the
time it takes to kind of have you know
human reaction time from you know you
see something happening you press a
button is about oh maybe one third of a
second uh maybe uh 300 milliseconds
something like that um and if you work
out
the um that means that the if it was
just an electrical signal bouncing
around your brain will be going for for
many hundreds of feet um in um maybe
even longer than that um in that period
of time so it's sort of bouncing around
in your brain before the signal gets out
to the point where it's going down a
nerve fiber to get to your finger to
move the muscle in your finger to make
you press the button type thing
and the question is can you detect any
of the oh i'm getting ready to press the
button the answer is you can detect some
of it you can detect it maybe 100
milliseconds 150 milliseconds i don't
know
but before the 300 milliseconds that it
takes to typically you know press the
button so you can start to detect
something but it's not clear that what
you detect is even what you wanted to
detect because for example you might say
well i'm thinking of moving my finger
but then you realize at the last minute
bad idea i shouldn't move my finger
there and your brain will will sort of
censor that motion and you won't do it
but you might have still picked up the
the activity associated with i'm
intending to move my finger
now there are other ways to detect sort
of activity in the brain as i say one is
to look at the these electrical effects
but they're it's hard from the outside
of the of the scalp it's hard to
detect for example an individual neurons
activity it's you just get this very
collective very kind of washed out thing
that mostly is these overall brain waves
and i think the thing that um uh there
have been various experiments on using
magnetic
effects of brain of nerve cells that
approaches to that there are a whole
variety of approaches to kind of sort of
do the signal processing to be able to
even from outside the brain detect
things better using electrical effects
now
sometimes you can imagine well what if
you actually implanted something in the
brain
and sometimes for medical conditions
like parkinson's disease there are
independent reasons to want to implant
things deep brain stimulators and things
in the brain that essentially are
sending electrical signals into parts of
the brain
to get it let's say to produce i don't
know dopamine a neurotransmitter in that
particular case or other kinds of things
and um uh that or things uh other for
other reasons there are like for
controlling epilepsy and so on there are
reasons to actually you know
sort of go in and implant some electrode
uh right on the surface of the brain or
even perhaps in the brain
and um so that then there are at least
some people who have the opportunity to
be able to uh both stimulate and pick up
information much more directly from sort
of inside the brain and one of the
things that's been a long-running issue
is can you
make something which is like like a
camera for example a modern digital
camera has this array of pixels might
have you know 10 million pixels or
something which are all little places
where the a a photon of light falling in
that particular place has an electrical
effect can you have something where you
have a similar sort of array where
you're detecting uh you know the effects
of lots and lots of nerve cells well
people are starting to do those kinds of
arrays they're getting bigger and bigger
and they're starting to work better and
better
there's another reason why those arrays
are sometimes really really useful which
is if you've damaged your spinal cord
which is the the main trunk of nerves
from the brain that controls all of your
main body muscles and so on if that's
damaged then and and you still want to
and then you know is there a secondary
pathway can you have something where you
have something which connects directly
to to your brain or to your spinal cord
which then allows you to then sort of uh
uh you know build your own sort of uh
waste station so to speak that transmits
nerve signals or possibly um just uh
transmit signals to some external device
that can move for you so to speak and
that's a thing which is a sort of
another case where where one's trying to
pick up
more or less individual nerve signals
now one thing to say about all of those
kinds of things
is that
when you are when you have a device like
that the device can learn oh this
particular nerve is the one that was
intended to move you know the left hand
or something this particular nerve was
intended to do that because they don't
come labeled um you know it's just
you've got a bunch of nerve fibers and
it's like what what does each of them do
and um uh but what tends to happen is
two things learn the machine learning
system perhaps that is the external
connection learns but also the person
who is trying to control those nerves
can learn oh if i make this nerve do
this
you know if i if i think this way
then that will cause this machine to
move that that thing because in the end
internally that's causing some
particular nerve fiber to get an
electrical signal i mean i suspect when
when we're all kind of in the baby stage
so to speak that's kind of a little bit
what's happening you know we're noticing
oh if we think this way then it causes
us to you know move our our you know our
hand in this fashion and so on and we
kind of have to learn by observing what
the consequences are we have to learn
what is the feeling that we have to have
uh that causes this particular motion to
occur i think it's probably true when
you when you are training you know when
you're learning any kind of sort of
physical skill it's the same kind of
thing you know what is that what does it
feel like to
uh you know do this particular exercise
or whatever else it is
um
i think that um
that's a uh uh so anyway so the sort of
one thing is these sort of direct
connections to nerves there are some
other ways you can kind of read out
what's happening inside brains the most
popular is this thing called fmri
functional magnetic resonance imaging
where the idea is
that this is uh like a an mri scanner
which um
talks some other time about how mri
scanners work well i can say how they
work basically the um
there's this
what happens is
um when you have a rapidly changing
magnetic field a strong rapidly changing
magnetic field
the um uh the the the nuclei of atoms
will tend to in that magnetic field the
nuclei of atoms are spinning around and
they have little tiny magnets on them
and in the magnetic field that you
produce those magnets will process
around they'll move around
and as you can pick up the effect of
that procession
when when it occurs so what happens is
your typical mri scanner is uh primarily
scanning for uh protons hydrogen nuclei
and the the um
the effect of of sort of where are their
hydrogen nuclei essentially for us where
is their water for instance
and um that uh uh it's a little bit more
complicated than that there are other
elements galileum is one common one
which have um which are particularly
visible or invisible in mri
but the basic point is you have this
magnetic field on the outside
and that's causing the magnetic field is
causing these uh hydrogen atoms to to
behave in a certain way and produce
their own uh electromagnetic
output
and and what happens is it's a the this
technique of tomography
where essentially what you're doing is
well the simpler cases with x-rays
cat scans computer-aided tomography um
where what you're doing is you're
looking at um
um you you're saying you're sending an
x-ray beam
through
through a piece of a person let's say
and what's happening is it's like you
might be like shining a flashlight
except that you know with a flashlight
with ordinary light if you shine a
flashlight through your hand it'll just
be a kind of dull red that comes out the
other side
because most of the light is absorbed
but with x-rays it's a higher frequency
of electromagnetic radiation and mostly
the x-rays just go straight through your
hand in a way that visible light does
not
but when it goes straight through your
hand it turns out your bones
it doesn't go as easily through your
bones as it goes through other things so
that's why and sort of a long ra long
convention that the bones show up white
on x-rays um even though really that's
the place where the x-rays didn't go
through um they didn't go through
because x-rays are sensitive to the uh
atomic number of elements
and so an x-ray when when an x-ray sort
of hits an atom the chance that the
x-ray is is
absorbed or scattered away
it goes up
rapidly with the um uh with the atomic
number so hydrogen it'll go through
helium will go through et cetera et
cetera et cetera by the time you're at
calcium which is what is in bones
the chance of it going through is much
lower and that's why bones don't why
x-rays don't as easily go through bones
but any case the way that tomography
works is usually you're saying you have
a a a sender and a receiver and you it's
like you're shining a flashlight in a
particular direction uh through and
you're recording in this particular
direction the flashlight got through
this much now change the direction
slightly now change it again for every
direction you're recording how much did
the flashlight x-ray flashlight so to
speak managed to get through you and if
you if you think about it if you imagine
that you could put down you know every
every path you think about you say how
much did it all together get through
going along this path you say i'm going
to i'm going to draw a picture i'm going
to put a strip of of i don't know um uh
some you know transparency strip that
who's whose gray level
is
uh is determined by the total amount
that managed to get through so very
little got through make it very let's
say make it very black if a lot got
through make it almost transparent and
let's say you you you take all these
strips and every every one of this
transmit receive direction you put down
a strip in that direction you just form
this this picture and then you say well
okay let's take this picture that i
formed by taking all these strips at all
these different angles just hold it up
to the light what does it look like well
it will look like
that that thing made from all those
different strips when you look at the
whole thing it will be it will have
correctly localized where in if in the
middle for example in some or off to one
side for example there's this place
where everything's getting absorbed
you'll see that because
the strips that went through there will
have been more absorbed when they went
in that direction and so on so that's
how you reconstruct and it's a computer
reconstruction that's how you
reconstruct kind of the slice
through the the person let's say for
computer edit tomography uh magnetic
resonance imaging works a little bit
differently it reconstructs a slightly
different slice but it's the same basic
idea
um and uh it's so that's a way that that
term so that detects for example for
detect some
the presence of hydrogen you can also
detect
the um
uh let's see that's that's the primary
thing you're detecting
you are detecting eventually activity
levels in the brain let's see how does
this work
there's a different technique positron
emission tomography which directly
detects um
glucose use
but i'm not i'm not i'm now
well the end result is that
where the mri
sort of
shows
i'm thinking how does this actually
detect activity um
essentially it's the
the places in your brain
where lots is going on
the when nerve cells are firing a lot
they're using up energy they're
consuming glucose
and you can detect that although i have
to admit that i'm a little bit i have to
think a little bit about exactly how
that all completely works but but the
basic idea is a part you know different
parts of your brain will be visible
as being sort of active on mri and so
then the question is what functional mri
is doing is it's looking if you ask
somebody you know imagine uh a an
elephant
imagine a teapot
imagine a whatever what you do is you do
that a whole bunch of times
and with a whole bunch of people
and you say does that consistently lead
to activity in different parts of the
brain
and the thing that's kind of a
surprising claim is that well yes it
does different people it's different
different people will have you know the
elephant area will be different in
different people but sort of everybody
has an elephant area if they know about
elephants type thing um and so there's a
certain amount you can learn from
functional mri from fmri
about kind of uh sort of the what
somebody is thinking about kind of
things so these are all ways to kind of
read out information from the brain um
in a way that is more
that isn't just wait for the person to
say something wait for them to actuate
you know the muscles in their vocal
tract or whatever else
um and uh
so this this idea of you know can you
make a direct neural connection
um to the brain is all about can you do
something which is better than what we
anyway get to do with our eyes and our
muscles and so on
now having done that so the next problem
is let's say you could actually have and
there are some optical schemes that for
doing it as well but but basically
you're putting let's say an electrode
array on the brain and you're trying to
pick up electrical signals from nerve
cells you may be trying to trying to
send electrical signals to nerve cells
what can you do with that well first
thing is the brain
is doing all kinds of complicated things
and
decoding
how to send a particular signal saying
you know
i don't know what um you know
don't eat that next
piece of chocolate or something sending
that kind of detailed signal to the
brain or you know you want an apple
rather than a piece of chocolate um
sending that level of detail to the
brain is really hard to see how to do
and you really have to be decoding
because one thing to say is that
people's brains even the layout you know
people have somewhat unique fingerprints
but the layout of people's brains is
quite different and if you ask the
question where do people even there are
certain things that are localized in the
brain like the language center of the
brain the place
in the brain that's that's critical to
producing uh language to saying things
and so on that area is very very where
it is in the brain
you know everybody will have one um but
where it is
uh moves around quite a lot from person
to person
and how one encodes information is
probably completely different from
person to person we see that in a
technological way with neural networks
and machine learning if you say here
i've got these two neural nets and
they're both going to learn the
difference between cats and dogs and
pictures you say let me do a brain
transplant from one neural net to the
other doesn't work not at the level of
individual you could you can maybe do it
where it's a pre-processing stage but if
you say does this particular arrangement
of neurons for this particular thing um
have uh you know can you sort of
transplant it this other one well no
because
it what it its way of encoding
information was different and the same
is true with human brains we can't
expect that any two brains will encode
information in the same way and you know
that means that so for any particular
brain this you know direct neural
connection will have to learn
how that particular brain encodes things
and and it's actually a thing that goes
right back to what i was talking about
with ai and computational language and
so on is well okay we've got to have a
representation that both we can talk
about and that we can kind of have
computers deal with about what that
brain is thinking of how do we represent
what that brain is thinking of there's
probably some intermediate language that
is in between the level of this neuron
is firing that neuron is firing this
this is happening that you know very
very detailed thing with individual
neurons and the level of the overall
kind of what we would say if we were
talking about things in language there's
probably an intermediate code that the
brain uses that is some kind of
intermediate representation of knowledge
we don't know what that is yet
um and
that and we haven't really seen that yet
in artificial neural networks either
that's something where you can train an
artificial neural network on sort of an
overall thing like cats versus dogs but
if you say well how did you break down
this you know distinction between cats
and dogs oh well it's this blob that
shows up here in the in a cat image and
you can see the whiskers there and you
can see whatever
we don't have a good way of representing
those kinds of things that the machine
learning system implicitly learned to do
it learned to do it at the level of
these individual pieces of algorithms
and weights and mathematics and so on
but it did that automatically and it did
that in a way where it doesn't have an
explanation to us about what it did
so i mean my answer about am i hopeful
about bringing computer interfaces in
the near future i've been waiting a long
time to be able to type by by from eeg
it hasn't worked yet
um i don't know i think um and it's not
even clear
if you
were you know
if if
you know one of the general principles
of of sort of signal processing
usually things that originally were just
oh you know you can't really get that
radio signal from here to there they'll
be the radio signal will be too
attenuated it'll be too absorbed by
things well eventually people manage to
figure out how to make just those right
kind of uh calibrations of the radio
signals that you can get it through so i
don't think it's the case i mean
uh you know back in the day people were
like wi-fi you know
uh radio communication between computers
and rooms and houses and this in cars
with metal and all this kind of thing
it's never going to work but in fact it
was made to work and it was made to work
by lots of engineering trickery of
noticing oh you compare the signal in
this case to the signal two milliseconds
later and you do this and you do that
and you encode the signal this way and
you have this and and that and
eventually it was made to work it would
be my guess that we'll be able to do the
same kind of thing with with brains and
that the the sort of the advantage of
having the electrodes all the way inside
the brain and all this kind of thing
maybe at the beginning that will be
necessary but in time there'll be enough
kind of signal analysis type
capabilities that you'll be able to take
something that's pretty externalized and
still be able to deal with it if you
could only understand sort of what the
brain was was how the brain was working
well enough and to send signals back
well that may be a little bit more
challenging um i think uh but again i'm
not sure that this
i mean you know for example one thing
that will surely come is augmented
reality where i mean there is there have
been test versions of this for
well for virtual reality for certainly
30 years um
more than that even and for augmented
reality something comparable to that
time where you know augmented reality is
you're looking at your at the visual
field
at you know you're looking out through
your glasses or whatever glasses will
probably become more fashionable when
augmented reality um becomes more of a
thing
and then sort of project it onto your
glasses somehow or maybe painted
directly on the back of your eye with a
laser that's scanning will be some sort
of overlay of uh you know something that
tells me you know something like oh
you're you know you're you're yakking
about this for a long time and you know
maybe you should yak about something
different or whatever else it is you
sort of
you know all sorts of annotation of the
world of you know you're walking through
a park somewhere and there'll be an
annotation this is the name of this type
of species this is the oh that's that
person you know who's walking towards
you or or that's some uh you know do you
notice this thing or that thing sort of
progressive um
uh sort of uh progressively more
annotation of a visual field i think
that will provide a pretty good
way of getting data into our brains um
probably pretty competitive i would
suspect
with many of the kinds of oh let me you
know connect directly into neurons in
the brain maybe not but i think that
will be a pretty good thing now in terms
of how you get the data out from the
brain
the kind of what were you thinking of
type thing i think that's a little bit
more challenging
i mean i think you know what we have now
is talking and typing and things like
that
um
whether there will be ways to i mean
even even for example eye motion
which is something so eye tracking you
know one's eyes
for example when you one's eyes move in
these things called sick ads where you
will fixate on a particular point and
then your eye will move and the small
motions but they're very fast and if you
look at how somebody is is looking at a
particular scene you'll see that they
will move in these little sick ads
they'll move all over the place and
little little kind of random walk in
these little jumps part of the reason
for those sick ads is that if you locked
the image of something on your retina
your you would essentially get burn-in
on your retina that is you would have a
particular particular thing in your
retina would would um uh would kind of
be a particular place on your retina oh
there's a piece of light that arrived
there it takes a little while for that
retinal cell to recover and it to be
able to receive another piece of light
so it's better for your eyes to move
slightly so that you're using different
retinal cells to see the next sort of uh
next
tenth of a second or something of image
in any case it's always interesting to
see you know when you look at eye
tracking um and and it's still
unfortunately a rather
a rather difficult thing to do i mean i
remember bacco 20 something years ago i
remember the first time i got an eye
tracking device it was a very you know
you had to bite down you know to
immobilize your head so that the thing
could look at your you know precisely it
could align your eyes precisely so that
because you know by the time you're
you're biting on something you're you
are you have you know you've got your
your skull is there and you're kind of
locked in place and then it would try
and look at the um
the the the pupils of your eyes and so
on and track where they went things have
become better since then and you can now
have things on your computer although
it's still not really consumerized to
the point where you can just have your
computer's camera
routinely just look at your eyes and
look at what you're looking at but
that's the thing that hasn't really
happened yet as a way to kind of get
some information from us i mean it's
been long used um uh you know if you if
you're trying to make up a website and
you wonder are people gonna notice this
thing on my website well you can run an
eye tracking experiment but we we tried
that about 20 years ago actually um we
tried that kind of thing and we kind of
gave up because it was all too much
trouble and it was a lot easier just to
see it's pretty obvious when people
whether people will notice this or not
um and you can just ask them did you
notice it or not but it is interesting
to see
from actual eye tracking you can see you
know
for example when you look at eye
tracking of somebody looking another
person you'll see that they will um uh
you know they'll they'll kind of eye
track if you look at where their eyes
are looking on a face for example
they'll look around the eyes they'll
look around the nose they'll look around
the mouth
and so on they'll look at these facial
features they'll concentrate on those as
they scan their eyes to sort of analyze
the face and you do that you know we all
do that
completely uh subconsciously it's it's
done um
it's controlled by the the cicad motion
is controlled by our brain stems it's
controlled by a low level part of our
brain that is some uh sort of quite
below the level of um uh
actually actually the let me see the the
some part of that i think some part of
the cicadas may be controlled by the
brainstem but there's some part that is
controlled by a thing called the lateral
geniculate nucleus
which is a a part uh in the center of
the brain
that um uh
um
when you for example if you see a big
blob we use this actually in our
notebook technology one of the issues is
when people are following along they're
typing they see their cursor typing
along and it's it's all good their eyes
manage to track the cursor they know
where they're gonna where the next
character is gonna go but if for some
reason the cursor has to jump backwards
because you rearranged the um because
you were typing a math expression or
something and it rearranged itself and
the cursor jumps backwards the question
is do people's eyes follow that jump
backwards and naturally they don't
they'll just keep trying to trace
forwards and they'll get lost and i'll
say what happened you know where am i
typing now so we we learned 25 years ago
now
we started doing this thing where we
produced this um we used to call it the
amazing shrinking blob um which is just
this big black blob that immediately
shows up when the cursor jumps the black
blob shows up on the screen and it
gradually in well in a small fraction of
a second squashes itself down to the
size of the cursor now it turns out that
that people's visual systems
automatically move their eyes to the
position of the big black blob people
you don't have to think about it just
happens automatically it's kind of like
probably it's kind of like from from
some distant past where you know some
predator might be about to attack and we
better notice that it's there and so we
we naturally move our eyes in that
direction and so for us that was a very
convenient thing to do because it meant
that people didn't lose that place
anymore their eyes would automatically
move to where the cursor is um they are
occasionally you know i think they're
sort of a trickle over the years of
people contacting tech support saying
there's this bug there's this black blob
that shows up on my screen uh we've
never quite figured out
whether there's a subpopulation of
people whose visual systems work faster
differently or something where they
notice the black blob but most people
don't even notice it they just move
their eyes
but in any case that that um uh but you
know you can so that's a that's a place
where we make use of that that um that
notion of of rap of eye motion um but i
think this is the thing which is not
that that's that's just making people
move their eyes as opposed to watching
where people move their eyes i have to
say i am very curious now because the
world has for better or worse um uh the
the um i'm not sure it's always
scientifically very convincing for
for for the particular virus we're
dealing with right now um you know we've
lived in a masked world for a couple of
years at least in many places
and so no doubt that means that when
people scan faces well you know they're
not going to scan the mask part of the
face and i don't know maybe that will
have some some long-term effect it'd be
an interesting study to do actually um
particularly on younger kids
about how they scan faces and what's
important in faces and so on um i think
masks are a very good thing for for
things like i don't know colds and
rhinoviruses and so not so not so
interesting for the case where they
whether you get aerosolized particles
that are much smaller and kind of don't
don't get caught in um in unless you're
actually sneezing so to speak but that's
a different topic
um
in any case that was a um
uh
i'm not sure how i got off i'm talking
about eye motion but that that's uh sort
of a different form of interaction
that's a different um uh
way of um
um
um
[Music]
a different different uh sort of way of
interfacing to the brain
um
so i have no means of keeping okay i
should should wrap up in a minute here
um
let's see
um
a lot of very interesting questions here
but i think they are
um
none of them
are going to be able to be
addressed in just a few moments here
[Music]
so
i think
we probably should uh
wrap up here for for today
and um thank you for lots of interesting
questions i i
um
uh
um
yeah i hope um
i think we are also now providing a web
form where people can enter questions
and topic areas
that you'd like me to try and try and
address
um in future
uh
future episodes here
um
but
for now thanks for joining us and
see you